you
uncle Joey hey you bad [ __ ] the
sun is shining the birds are chirping
it's a beautiful fun-filled day in
America understand you got work you're
alive you're healthy who the [ __ ]
gonna stop you now yong-chol Joey I'm
saying still recovering from a thousand
milligrams last night and then
ninety-two bong hits of Gorilla Glue how
do we open the day with gorillas Widow
[ __ ] around
okay it might be a little [ __ ] a
fourth of July weekend for some people
you sitting there go generally it's
gonna be gravely a potato salad the old
gives up [ __ ] I'm gonna get down [ __ ]
you understand but you've got to get
down to the ground today because this
Thursday July you understand me it's
that time of year you got to break up
the rear you got to bring up the hotdogs
if you got to do things
but before you go in here to start with
there's the meditation of the days and
then you gotta sit back a little couple
hits jump out of your body having a
little out-of-body experience and look
at yourself doing the things that you
want to do you follow me this is easy
you don't need to bid on [ __ ] Swahili
ingenious here you just say to yourself
I want to make happen today let me write
down three things if two of them happen
I'm already ahead of the game understand
and that's it I got a big day today I'm
kind of I'm breathing you know why
because I got this 11:15 tonight at the
store
I know 3:15 I don't want a clock I might
just go to burn it don't [ __ ] melt my
sitting there
we're gonna be a man's man that's it
that's no more they gotta be a man's
[ __ ] man every damn top everything I
gotta be a man gentlemen nice you know
you gotta pick up paper gonna be kind to
[ __ ] strange animals the little things
anybody could be popular to [ __ ] stop
but how you doing three days from Egypt
I hope your [ __ ] plane goes down
concept of Egypt let me fly in this
weekend
oh yeah
I'll put the pieces together to express
myself with you is a piece of cake
you forgot to put your [ __ ] that into
it eliminate the riffraff eliminate the
who booze eliminate the stupid whatever
nope yeah it don't really matter if they
have like my [ __ ] life why am I
sitting here talking to these people how
is this kind of effect
oh yeah
that's it just getting ready for my
special wanted to be the best you can be
I'm representing the church
and that's it trying to be a better
person every [ __ ] day you can't
become Fresno but I you just make a
little [ __ ] strife
because I both
was a real fun
they prevent all a little [ __ ]
amateur eyeballs you see at the weed
school I smoke the 22nd
nice
these little puppets
I can't wait to see the final one for
how all the week how old
I was breaking the living room my wife
yelled from the kitchen
that's love this [ __ ] punch have a
good night's sleep seven feet deep with
the coffee things started moving I think
of breathing what's Bubble Guppies world
are you nuts
people are now by you on [ __ ] stuff
body womping what do you want you know
me you know the [ __ ] soldier it that
but sometimes you bump into a pipe you
know thanks know things they don't blow
in your favor
but checking what you savages
I'm feel right behave yourself guys
they're coming keep your eyes on the
[ __ ] plane even then send them a
[ __ ] pigeon with a note the flick I'm
saying you've got time to be doing down
why is that dude there why is that dude
moving funny why did that dude talk a
little walkie-talkie stay black I got
you I'm with you you would mean